pourrez créer votre chaîne youtube et
pour le moment elle ne décolle pas
particulièrement vous vous demandez
pourquoi je faisais les raisons et je
vais vous donner les cinq points
principaux qui peuvent bloquer dans
votre existence youtube et vous empêcher
de gagner mais vu les connards qui en a
donné une empreinte sur youtube je vais
vous expliquer comment les identifier
comment les solutionner et enfin réussir
sur youtube de plus en plus de chaînes
belges jour sur youtube et il est
extrêmement difficile d'y réussir
cependant à giroud toutes les astuces et
mes meilleures techniques pour gagner
des vues des abonnés et enfin réussir
sur youtube
inscrivez-vous à la chaîne et activer la
cloche pour ne manquer aucune vidéo
si vous voulez aller plus loin pour
réussir sur youtube cliquez sur le lien
pour rejoindre la communauté alors du
tout si vous posez la question du jour
quels sont selon vous les d'erreur vous
communiquerez youtube quel qui vous
empêche de réussir est ce que vous
arrivez à identifier les points
bloquants
si vous les identifier vous pourrez du
boulet corriger et progresser marqué
notre documentaire on regarde quels sont
les points bloquants qui ont réussi dans
des chutes et pour moi il existe cinq
erreurs principales pour commis sur
youtube quand on débute et qui vous
empêche de progresser
si votre chien ne progresse pas si elle
est très longue à progresser j'ai très
très longue évolué et que vous n'avez
pas beaucoup de lui du coup assez peu
d'abonnés
vous êtes frustrés fait relativement
normal mais rassurez vous son identifier
les points qui bloquent si on identifie
les erreurs que l'on commet on peut
progresser et on va progresser le point
numéro un vous passez plus de temps sur
votre production que sur votre contenu
vous passez plus de temps avoir un bon
micro une bonne lumière une voix de
caméras y avoir une belle qualité
forcément la plupart du temps au regard
des chaînes qui nous plaît c'est cher
d'une très bonne qualité
parce qu'elles ont des vues l'expérience
et qu'elles ont embrassé un accident de
caunes efforts qui leur permettent
aujourd'hui d'avoir la bonne lumière la
bonne caméra le bon micro donc tout va
bien et vous voulez absolument ressemble
à rien de ce que vous pensez que c'est
une des clés de la réussite sauf que oui
effectivement mais c'est pas la première
la première chose à mettre en place et
passer plus de temps sur son contenu
quel est votre corps nu de quoi parlez
vous quelles histoires racontées vous et
de quelle manière
comptez-vous ça fait extrêmement
important les gens ne veulent pas
forcément voit de belles images les unes
après les autres
il faut que ces belles images qui
existent vous permettre de raconter une
histoire alors cette histoire
posez vous la question de quoi parle
votre chienne quelle histoire de
raconter et de quelle manière vous
souhaitez la raconter quand vous avez
une des vidéos à fait dit vous prenez un
papier un crayon et imaginer la manière
dont vous voudrez cat histoires sont
racontées
notez tout ça fait discret dandy
storyboard et ça vous aidera d'une pour
la réalisation de cette vidéo et pour le
montage et vous verrez ça va marcher et
à voir numéro 2 vouloir faire tout et
n'importe quoi
je les fais je suis passé par là
rassurez-vous tout le monde passe par là
ses débuts on aime énormément de chaîne
dans plusieurs thématiques et on dit ben
si lui mars la et du nord cela pourquoi
est ce que je pourrais faire un petit un
peu de ça et ça ne paraîtra progressé
sur tous les domaines sauf que en
réalité ça marche pas du tout comme ça
vous voulez faire du blog d'une vidéo de
l'high-tech du sport la santé et tous
ces domaines là la plupart du temps les
mélanges dans le mélange très très mal
ensemble pour centrer vous sur un point
et un seul trouver votre niche la
question vous poser quelques problèmes
solutionner vous pourquoi est-ce qu'on
irait s'abonner à votre chaîne
aujourd'hui il ya énormément de chaîne
sur youtube et n'auront d'autre beaucoup
de chaînes qui parlent de la même chose
et qui traite des problèmes de la même
manière quelqu'un qui va regarder vos
vidéos ne veut pas regarder la même
chose qui a déjà vu ailleurs surtout que
la plupart du temps c'est moins bien
fait moins bien réalisé l'originalité
n'est pas l'arbre trouvé le sujet qui
vous correspond sur lequel vous avez une
vraie expertise et trouver de quelle
manière vous allez pouvoir aider ceux
qui regardent nos vidéos pour ça
forcément envahi il faut avril ont
quitté son audience qui voulez vous
aider et de quelle manière voulez vous
le faire une fois que vous avez trouvé
ça vous traiter de ce sujet et que de ce
sujet si vous avez un sujet qui est
connexe
vous pouvez faire mais si vous et non un
univers qui n'a rien à voir il y aura
pas forcément peau et les os
perdu est-ce que d'une base abonnés
voire pire de se désabonner ever numéro
3 trop produire sans stratégie de
contenus quand on commence on est
enthousiaste qu'on a envie que ça marche
on veut faire un maximum de vidéos
vous avez raison sauf que si vous n'avez
pas une vraie stratégie convenue entre
clairvoyance par rapport à youtube
comment marche youtube et comment
aurélie sur youtube vous avez très peu
de chances que ça marche
au début on produit beaucoup de vidéos
on est motivé on fait un maximum de
vidéos on passe beaucoup de temps le
faire souvent pas trop de temps sur la
production et au final vous avez
beaucoup de vidéos et aucune vidéo qu'il
marche du coup pas de vue pas d'abonnés
vous vous décourager et la plupart du
temps c'est à ce moment là on arrête et
qu'on brade youtube
si vous avez compris comment je suis du
commandant tiago rythme youtube comment
mettre en place la bonne stratégie
vous allez progresser il faut absolument
comprendre comment fonctionne le
référencement sur youtube comment
trouver les bons mots clés les bonnes
expressions clés qui permettront être
suggérées dans la colonne de droite
en page d'accueil et de sortir dans les
résultats de recherche sont des requêtes
particulières
d'ailleurs pour ça je vous invite à
aller voir cette vidéo qui va vous aider
à progresser
si vous ne pourriez pas arrêter tout
pour comprendre comment marche le tube
met en place la bonne stratégie et
ensuite vous allez pouvoir produire
faire des vidéos en respectant cette
stratégie et vous allez voir vous allez
croître sur youtube quatrième point les
chaînes ont déjà spectraux pas la crise
nous donne un aspect professionnel avec
shane si quelqu'un avec sur votre chaîne
si elle a peint un aspect professionnel
si elle que vraiment trop bricolage
la plupart du temps les gens ne vont pas
s'abonner il est très rare que l'on
s'abonne en cliquant sous une vidéo sur
le bouton s'abonner la plupart du temps
on regarde une vidéo si elle vous plaît
vous allez sur la chaîne de la personne
qui l'a créé hélas si l'univers vous
plaît qui toutes les vidéos sont
cohérentes à répondre à votre
problématique
à ce moment là on va s'abonner c'est
super important de ne pas négliger la
description sa chaîne sa bannière sa
photo son aspect général sur la page
d'accueil organisée
votre contenu en playlist créer des
playlists il faut quand on arrivait
contrôle on voit effectivement des
choses qui sont cohérentes quelques
secondes à des problématiques qui seront
traités d'une façon intelligente
cela en dit soit tu cries rendra envie
de parcourir votre vidéo d'en voir plus
à ce moment là vous allez voir votre
compteur de vue va augmenter et le
nombre d'abonnés de la même manière
travailler votre marque
valorisez votre marque travailler vos
vignes est fait de belles vignettes et
vous verrez si vous avez un écosystème
l'ensemble vraiment cohérent les abonnés
vont venir erreur numéro 5 vouloir aller
trop vite
forcément quand on débute on a envie ça
beaucoup de vidéos on a envie que ça
marche on se donne à fond et on comprend
pas tout de suite ça ne prenne pas il
est strictement impossible en votant
tels que vidéo d'avoir une croissance
exponentielle
il ya peu de temps 10 codes à une
croissance fulgurante avec une ou deux
vidéos mais c'est extrêmement rare la
plupart du temps il faut beaucoup de
temps beaucoup de travail
une stratégie cohérente et mises en
place pour progresser
si vos vidéos une marque ensuite prenez
sedan mettait en place la bonne
stratégie
prenez pas en corriger les points et
vous donniez précédemment mettez en
place la bonne stratégie vous allez voir
votre chaîne va aux nantais ne soyez pas
trop pressé on n'est pas la charrue
avant les boeufs vous produisez du
contenu qui est cohérent dans une niche
cohérente vous avez donc ici une
problématique à solutionner et vous
allez voir ensuite votre compteur de vue
d'augmenter vos vies vont se transformer
en abonnés et vous allez croître et vous
allez très heureux toute façon vite vous
bien que youtube est le deuxième moteur
de recherche au monde après google
youtube appartient à google
donc il faut un certain temps pour vos
vidéos se référencent prom s'est pas
fait en un jour et rassurez vous votre
chaîne youtube ne sera pas non plus en
un jour
ces failles d'erreur la plupart du temps
tous les 10 du temps les fonds ne vous
découragez pas si vous vous trompez
c'est normal maintenant vous avez
identifié vos problèmes vous n'avez plus
qu'à les corriger et en place les bonnes
pratiques et vous verrez vous allez
enfin réussir sur youtube merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo à bonnevoie machine
parce qu'il y aura encore plus de
contenu pour vous aider à réussir sur
youtube
si la vidéo vous a aidé
des éléments de réponse vous invite à
laisser un joli poussé puis met des mots
en commentaire un tout nouveau projet
valiquer vos idées et vos suggestions
par rapport à cette vidéo quant à moi je
remercie d'ailleurs les vidéos et je
vous dis à bientôt